The school students have to open the
bank account in which the government
sends money for school dress and
copies. Is the money sent by government
to Muslim students halal for them to
use? Is the scholarship money halal to
use? I'm a widow. Is widow pension halal
for a Muslim lady in India? Is Russian
food material provided by the government
of India halal for Muslims to use? Is
ladi scheme halal for a Muslim student?
Please answer.
The question posed was that they get
various benefits for the children
whether it be scholarships whether it be
food the woman get benefits of the widow
pension or larely scheme means that if
you have
a daughter and if you take care of the
daughter the government gives you some
amount every year it depends maybe some
5,000 depending upon the state in which
has a lar scheme so that they encourage
you having more daughters and yearly
they give you maybe 5,000 rupees for 5
years or some give more so that it helps
you economically. So is it allowed to
take from the government the money may
be haram they may be involving in etc.
The first part of the question says that
you have to open account and they put
the money in the account. See to it that
you open a current account since there
are no Islamic banks in India and you're
living in Delhi. My request to you would
be see to it that you opened a current
account. A current account does not have
any interest. So if you open a
conventional bank, you have no option.
You have no Islamic banks in India. So
you open a bank account and a
conventional bank but a current account.
A current account which has no interest.
A savings account is account which is
saving but has interest but less amount.
And then there's fixed deposit. So
opening a fixed deposit account or a
saving account is haram in a
conventional bank. So since there are no
Islamic banks, you open a current
account and the current account may be a
little bit difficult to open but it's
possible once you open a current account
and if you get money from the government
whether as scholarship for your child or
for the widow pension or as a lad scheme
even assuming that the money of the
government is from wrong means maybe
from interest or maybe based is it halal
for you to take or not? According to
fatwa by
Islamia that if a person acquires the
wealth in a haram way but if he gives
you in a legal way for example a person
is dealing in ribba he gets a lot of
money but that money which he earns if
he gifts it to you gifts it to you or
gives you as reward gifting is halal
giving as a reward is allowed if he
earned in a haram way the sin is on him
but if that money is gifted to you or
has been rewarded to you for you to
accept that money is halal. It's
permitted. He will get the sin for
earning in the haram way. Similarly, I'm
a doctor. If a person working in a bank,
a manager comes for treatment and he's
earned it in the haram way. I'm a
medical doctor. I'm taking fees. For me,
it's allowed. For him earning the haram
way, he will get the but me as a medical
doctor taking money. He might have
earned it in the haram way. But me
taking my fees is allowed. Similarly,
someone gives you gift taking gift is
permitted. So he doing a sin for you it
is allowed. So similarly if it's a
non-Muslim government whether it be
Indian government or government in the
western country is giving you some
benefit as a citizen or giving some
scholarship. As long as you are a
citizen it is a right to take
scholarship that money even earned in
the haram way for you it is halal except
in certain cases. And same thing when
binbas was as fatwashik binbas he said
as long as you are taking in the halal
way and the person giving you does not
force you to do something haram. For
example if someone gives you gift and
say that you promote a conventional bank
which is ribba based then that is haram.
So while giving the gift he does not
impose on you anything which is haram
then taking that gift is permitted. If
he asked to do something which is halal
no problem. If okay come and give tions
to my kids okay no problem it's halah
but if he imposes something which is
haram or tells you to promote something
which is haram then taking that money is
not permitted but if he's not imposing
something haram on you taking that money
is permitted and secondly what you have
to realize that as long as the product
according to shik bimbas if it's a
product for example he has robbed
something and if it's a stolen property
Then he's giving you a gift. The rob
property has to be returned to the
owner. Then you cannot take that rob
property. So if he's earned it in a
haram way, whether it be by selling
alcohol or by ribba, then it's
permitted. But if you robbed something
and you come to know it is robbed, then
it has to be returned to the rightful
owner. But otherwise, if the government
gives you something, even if it's not
from a halal source, you as a Muslim,
you can accept it. It's halal for you.
Hope that answers the question.